good morning job so I've been thinking a
lot about YouTube lately what it is what
it does what is happening to it
maybe maybe maybe I've been having a
little bit of a creative crisis lately
which is not unusual it happens to me
it's part of my cycle and of course
YouTube has never been a static thing
it's been changing constantly and
vlogbrothers has changed over the years
as well as YouTube becomes a bigger
cultural force and more people are
paying attention to it in big cities
with suits on I'm just thinking about
what's gonna happen to this place that
we have come to long it's starting to me
to look more like the old system with
fewer pots with more money in each pot
instead of lots of pots with the money
spread out more money is fine but not
fewer pots so I'm getting a little bit
worried that in the future with the big
stuff we'll be able to support itself a
99% of the people will watch 1% of the
content the 1% of the content will be
the same like boring stuff that's
currently on television and there will
be no new innovation and no new cool
things happening and there will be rich
people who have a vested interest in
keeping it that way and I don't want to
inflate the power of the people watching
this video and I don't want to put too
much responsibility on their shoulders
but I think it's our job to make sure
that that stuff doesn't happen and I
don't think is gonna be that hard but I
also don't think that it's gonna happen
on its own one of the perks we offered
for the project for Austin this year was
to decide the topic of a bond brothers
video and a lot of those will be
uploaded unlisted and people will be
able to see them but they won't go live
to all subscribers but Barbie still
asked us to just make a video about
something the vlogbrothers care a lot
about and so this video is for her
because online video is very important
to me I'd run VidCon for crying out loud
and I think online video is more than
important to me I think that it's
important culturally right now and I
think it's going to be important
historically so I want people to be
conscious of what's going on right now
about how we consume content - the kind
of stuff that we like and what makes
this reward and what makes it different
you know and so I want to keep doing
things with the other side of the camera
you know one the Hanks face remix
contest I put a tracker - a torrent of
the Hanks face stems and people who know
how to remix video you can remix that
into whatever you wanted the person who
wins will get prizes and glory and who
cares will probably maybe we'll figure
out something but mostly you'll care
second the diff master award some have
talked about this and we think that
animated gifs are an underappreciated
art form and so if you would like to
create some exceptionally good gifs it
doesn't have to be vloggers just it can
be whatever you
but you can tag them with jiff master
and we'll go through those tags and we
will select winners of the jiff Master
Award and they may actually give me
something physical to go along with this
but I'm not guaranteeing anything
because you know what happens when we
guarantee stuff third I'm miss vlogging
more and so I'm gonna be vlogging every
day in April and I encourage you to do
the same and fourth I want to change the
business of content I don't like it the
way that it is that much the business
part I like the content part very much
obviously but I don't like that you can
have a project with the brain scoop that
has 50,000 really dedicated people in
its community but still like can't pay
for itself like can't be self-sustaining
cuz I don't don't think advertising is
the right model I don't even like
advertising really my can't that's a
bigger thing I can't have time for that
right now I don't want to change the
content I want to change the model which
hopefully will lead to more better
content and I need help with this and so
designers developers there's a link in
the description for how to apply to work
with me on this also if you have any
short snappy domain names if you like to
would not use Annalee I just want to
talk about this so in the comments and
in our pants and on the nerdfighter
subreddit and wherever else
conversations happen in nerdfighteria
let's talk about what we love about
nerdfighteria about how to broaden
instead of narrowing about how we
discover content and about what we find
rewarding and interesting about online
video and and just content in general
and do you think maybe that there might
be a better way to fund it because I'm
tired of watching all the fancy
businessí people that I meet trying to
apply their old rules to our new system
let's make some new rules John I'll see
you on Tuesday
[Music]